we're going to begin of course in
minneapolis where the derrick chauvin
trial resumes this morning
with prosecutors expected to call
investigators and then
expert witnesses to testify about george
floyd's death
yesterday we heard very emotional
testimony from several witnesses
including a little nine-year-old girl
who watched
fired police officer kneel on floyd's
neck for more than nine
minutes jamie yukas is covering the
trial jamie
why was their testimony so significant
it was very difficult
to hear those little voices
i think it was not only difficult but it
was impactful the state's hoping that
those young people gail who testified
will make a big impression on the jury
we know one juror is a grandmother who
studied child
psychology and could understand how
witnessing this traumatic event
may have changed these young people's
lives again we do want to warn you the
video is disturbing
prosecutors witnessed darnella frazier
was 17 years old when she saw derek
jovan kneeling on george floyd's neck
i heard george floyd saying i can't
breathe
please get off of me i can't breathe
he cried for his mom he was in pain
she recorded the nearly 10-minute video
of floyd's death
it's been nights i stayed up
apologizing and
and apologizing
to george floyd for not doing more and
not physically interacting and
not saving his life darnell's
nine-year-old cousin judea reynolds was
with her that day
and saw the same scene i was sad
and kind of mad it felt like he was
stopping his breathing
and it is kind of like hurting him how
hard is it
to have a teenager and a nine-year-old
take the stand
extremely difficult because jurors are
human beings
criminal defense attorney joe tamborino
is not affiliated with the case
no one as any human being will tell you
that has any heart
wants to see a child in trauma or wants
to see a child
relive trauma i mean how from the
defense side can you ever cross-examine
the defense did not press the young
witness but central to their case is the
claim that officers perceived the people
there
to be a threat and they were distracted
by them you call them a bum
at least 13 times that's what you
counted in the video
that's what i counted yeah she got 13.
those
terms grew more and more angry they grew
more and more pleading for life when i
stayed in my body
you can't pay me out to be angry on his
second day on the witness stand donald
williams explained why he called 9-1-1
after watching derrick chauvin kneel on
george floyd's neck
i did call the police on the publix and
why did you do that
because i believe i witnessed a murder
genevieve hansen a minneapolis emt and
firefighter
was off duty that day you think that's
okay
she said she pleaded with the officers
to administer aid or allow her to
you couldn't do that how did that make
you feel totally distressed
defense attorney eric nelson asked
hansen if she would be able to properly
do her job as a firefighter
if a crowd of people were trying to
interfere you wouldn't be distracted by
that at all
what if they started calling you names
like i said
i know my job and i i would be confident
in doing my job
tamborino says the defense's case lies
in whether they are able to present
crystal clear medical evidence that
something other than chauvin kneeling on
george floyd's neck killed him
he also says after all of this powerful
testimony
the defense may want to consider putting
chauvin on the stand
adriana jamie thank you